[Music]
Christina Aguilera it's been 2 years
since we last saw her on the voice and
some people are surprised at how clear
she is making it'll be the last the
thing that I love about this show is
it's about bringing people up I loved
the whole crew and the cast Christina
now
describes the voice as a quote a turning
hamsterwheel and energy sucker and an
unfiltered new interview with billboard
she explains why she left the NBC
ratings juggernaut in 2016 for good
saying quote you realize it's not about
music it's about making good TV moments
I didn't get into this business to be a
television show host and to be given all
these rules but one TV show Christina
does embrace from her past the Mickey
Mouse Club yes some classic balls in the
vault stuff billboard showed her this
classic mouse performance from 1994
she's singing thing along sided then 12
year old Britney Spears
I love this little outfit they look like
little puppies like what
Brittany's future videos on me from
now the 37 year old mom of 2 is gearing
up for her first studio album in more
than five years called liberation the
music video for accelerate was released
today the single was co-produced by
Kanye West however his name was left out
of the official press release et has
learned that it had nothing to do with
the drama surrounding his recent rants
[Music]
[Applause]